this is such a cool show
it's such a cool show and you do like
it's funny when you see pictures of you
and call in side by side around the same
age it's like
you could be twins it's amazing
i'm assuming you spent some time with
him um before you went ahead and did
this or maybe even during is there
anything that he said to you that helped
you get started or inspired you
um i think the the big inspiration for
me was realizing how much of our history
sort of intertwined there's a sort of
light conversation there about how you
know
we
found music uh similar kinds of music at
the same time you know we were listening
to the far side at the same time and you
know um
you know resenting bone thugs and
harmony at the same age rather at the
same age um
but um
you know and watching the backyard again
which to me is kind of funny because
like
he's so much older than me and he's a
legend and why would we watch like the
same stuff but um
there's a deeper conversation there
about how we both
are
growing up and realizing that we're sort
of alienated from parts of of our
culture parts of american culture and
parts of american society and i think
that deeper conversation lends to a lack
of change in america and a lack of
change um over generations i feel like a
lot of people try and say that um
why why would you stand why would you
rebel what is there to rebel against
um why are you kneeling um everything's
fine there's no racial injustice we've
gotten so much better you know just just
wait um and the fact that there are
generation after generation doctor
generation of people who are
feeling and noticing the same sentiment
of of separation and and and
microaggression and lack of fairness
um only lends to the fact that there is
um
a dis disconnection and and a lack of of
a positive change
yeah and the show
so
um so definitely tackles all of these
things at the same time highlighting
what it's like
you know to be a teenager to go through
all these ups and downs um
what i'm thinking about you know
that instagram post that you did
celebrating ava on her birthday it was
such a warm
thing it just seems like you guys were
such a family what was it like
having her as a leader on this project
i think that's what um makes uh makes or
breaks a a a project um having a family
having
a place where you can feel comfortable
to be
vulnerable having a place where you feel
comfortable to
be the character where everyone feels
encouraged and has the right energy to
come to work every day and be empowered
to deliver their full um potential and
having ava as
um
as a leader um not only as someone to
you know give her power to everyone and
and give her her ideas and her insight
but
even more importantly she you know she
wanted a majority of the crew to be uh
people of color and to me i've been you
know in the film industry for 15 years
and it was the first time on any project
where i had seen a person of color
holding a boom um i'd never seen that
before and
and and then another parts of the crew
as well and it it's
it's it's sad when you think about it
that that
why haven't i seen this why why why
aren't my people having these these um
these positions but the fact that ava
is giving us a chance to to to have
greater positions and and um
be able to to do what we love and have
good great careers um
kind of created a great community on set
you know um you didn't have to feel like
oh i have to be friends with you because
you're the one other black person on set
um yeah we're all part of this family
and we're all so um passionate about
telling the story about telling colin's
story um so it was great
it absolutely reads in the performances
it's captured on camera i sincerely hope
everybody watches this man
congratulations
thank you